is it true what people think of Alabama
like these are coastal Elites like is
there any truth to it no it's good folks
down there man no we don't think that
they're not good we just think that
they're slow dumb no yeah
we don't even think that they're slow or
down so what do you think just have some
super fine cousin
[Laughter]
there are certain pockets of the South
the other things going on they're not
even people and the rest of the South
will come down so so you look at them
you never had no cousin if that's is
that what you're trying to ask I'm not
asking you I thought that was a
Caucasian thing I thought it was
Caucasian people where the cousin didn't
know that black people were involved no
that's not that's right yeah
yeah
take that family reunion t-shirt off